es ist der traum arbeitsplatz für
astronauten die internationale
raumstation iss sie umkreist die erde in
400 tausend metern höhe gemeinsam
betrieben von den usa europa japan
russland und kanada
claudia kessler wäre gern selbst dorthin
geflogen schon ihr ganzes leben lang
begeistert sie sich für das weltall
da kribbelt es mich immer wieder wenn
ich also raumfahrt hardware sagen wir ja
einfach live zum anfassen satelliten
oder auch raumstation raketen usw
weil das einfach mein kindheitstraum war
in der raumfahrt zu arbeiten selbst
astronauten zu werden das tollste vom
vom traum so ungefähr gewesen aber
überhaupt die vorstellung in der
raumfahrt zu arbeiten
sie studierte luft- und raumfahrttechnik
doch für das bewerbungsverfahren als
astronautin kam sie zu spät
nur alle zehn bis zwölf jahre werden
neue kandidaten gesucht sie ging neue
wege gründete eine personalagentur
claudia kessler vermittelt experten für
die raumfahrtindustrie die hälfte davon
frauen
vor allem die will sie gewinnen denn
ingenieurinnen oder technikerinnen gibt
es in der branche noch immer viel zu
wenige in deutschland ist man noch so
ein bisschen zurückhaltung der frauen da
was diese technischen berufe angeht was
einfach von der gesellschaft getrieben
ist die berufe man auch so ein bisschen
image von karierten hemd und cordhose so
ein klassischer lehrte ingenieur
davon müssen wir wegkommen in der
raumfahrt das ist es auch nicht da gibt
es ganz spannende dinge dass es eine
große bandbreite an an berufen und an
möglichkeiten die gerade auch für frauen
geboten werden zum beispiel bei metz hat
einem ihrer auftraggeber hier werden die
daten der vier europäischen
wettersatelliten gesammelt und
ausgewertet
von der zentrale gehen sie an
wetterdienste in mehr als 30 ländern
über 90 prozent der mitarbeiter sind
männer
natalie cocu fühlt sich trotzdem nicht
als exotin schon in der schule stand für
sie fest dass die physikerin werden will
die französin hat dann in deutschland
studiert von claudia kessler wurde sie
vor zwei jahren an und vermittelt wetter
satelliten auswerten für die daten
experte in einen bereich in dem sie
schon immer gern arbeiten wollte dass es
in ihrem beruflichen umfeld zu wenige
frauen gibt daran hat sie sich gewöhnt
klasse im gymnasium so ist schon lange
für mich es ist nicht neu aber ich bin
jetzt bereit das inzwischen ist halt
nicht sich nicht so viel geld also ich
wusste es gibt nicht so viele frauen
aber als ich hierhergekommen bin ich hat
das vielleicht in die letzte 20 oder 15
jahre so mehr frauen würden sich für
solche beruf entschieden
gute leute werden in deutschen
raumfahrtunternehmen dringend gesucht
wie bei der firma ohg einem der größten
deutschen hersteller von wetter und
nachrichten satelliten ebenfalls ein
kunde von kesslers personalagentur die
nachfrage nach hoch spezialisierten
fachleuten ist in den letzten jahren
stark gestiegen
gute karrierechancen also für frauen
doch bei claudia kessler bewerben sich
häufiger ingenieur innen aus spanien
italien oder frankreich als aus
deutschland sie will dass sich das
ändert mein wunsch wäre ja dass wir
endlich mal eine deutsche astronautin
fliegen würden um so auch mal ein
wirklich tolles rollenmodell für mädchen
zu haben die sagen können mensch so was
kann ich auch und die dadurch vielleicht
auch haben dazu führt dass mehr mädchen
sich in die technik trauen und in die
raumfahrt
technik
ihr wunsch könnte schon bald in
erfüllung gehen noch in diesem jahr soll
der auswahlprozess für die erste
deutsche raum fahrerin auf der
internationalen raumstation beginnen
gesucht werden geeignete anwärterin für
den traumjob im weltall